how could the greeks prove that the atom
existed and what does that have to do
with being happy
watch video to find out okay the greeks
dopest people that ever lived they
figured out all this stuff for us our
politics the sports math
law medicine you name it baby but most
importantly philosophy
thank you greek person
as we discuss on this channel before
they even dig into topics like how to be
happy the stoix talks about this topic a
lot aristotle pondered about this a lot
soak retains you know did we benefit so
much from the greeks but why does it
seem like still so many people are
unhappy bro if you're sad just don't be
sad well i read epicurus the art of
happiness and i think it highlights
pretty well why why so many people are
still unhappy to this day epicurism is
quite similar to stoicism in many ways
there's a few
determining factors don't need to get
into the nitty-gritty this is not an
expert essay i'm literally i'm doing
this video and hope that people will
continue their exploration
and discover epicurus and read the book
themselves basically um i was going to
say a great way to understand epicurism
is by just looking at the title
i thought the title was the
the science of happiness apparently the
art of happiness they
it should be the signs of happiness they
messed it up i'm just gonna pretend that
that's what the book is called the signs
of happiness thank you because epicurism
was using science as a fundamental for
everything god damn it this completely
ruined my point
by understanding things they alleviate
your fear from them people feared the
gods for example they were quite
wrathful people back in the ancient
greek and uh
you know christianity people fear hell
it's a similar concept but their view
was uh more eggnog agnostic in the sense
that the gods
don't really interact with us we're
there's no re don't worry about them
basically and from the principle of
science therefore you know the the
ancient greeks explain all this natural
phenomena by these amazing stories you
know helios
the sun god being this chariot that
carried the sun across the sky and all
these uh
stories to explain these natural
phenomena but the epicureans didn't
believe in this they they understood
that there's a way to explain everything
you can explain the heavenly bodies and
what they are and they're not there
because of the gods necessarily or
if you see a rainbow there's a natural
way of explaining why it occurs it's not
some
it's not it's not some irish dude hiding
a bunch of treasure in the end of this
book they have all these they go through
all these natural
occurrences and they try and explain
them but they don't necessarily say oh
we know for sure this is how it is so
even though it isn't great you know they
don't explain everything perfectly
obviously i that's still what science is
they do their best of trying to explain
things um from how they observe it but
there's one thing that epicurus in
particular
knew for sure which is the existence of
the atom which i think is so cool when i
heard about this first time i was like
what how how did they figure that out
i'm sorry what they figured out the atom
existed 2000 years ago
why so he knew this based on two
principles number one that we we can all
observe is that bodies move
yeah
number two is the principle that nothing
comes into the existence from nothing
this was a principle that was uh known
throughout at this time by some at least
that upheld it as far as i understand
and it kind of
goes with the whole point that they
didn't try and explain natural
occurrences as something magical made up
by the gods but rather trying to
understand how they come into existence
based on other things they basically
understood that for anything to occur
there has to be a reason for it to occur
or next there's an explanation
for why it happens those are the two
things so these bodies that we observe
we can break down into pieces anyone can
understand that but epicures knew that
this process of breaking down into
pieces it can't go on forever because
then it would break the law that the
bodies would dissolve into nothing
eventually if you repeat this process so
he understood that there has to be
one singular non-compound entity
that exists which
is the atom there you go another thing
that he believed was that the universe
is infinite you know which isn't
hypothetically false at least it's not
impossible so i don't know i just think
it's cool so they figured out all this
scientific stuff felix okay great what
about it how do i become happy well so
their actual philosophy epicurism
philosophy is technically hedonistic
which means indulging in pleasures and
that's what they value
now as it turns out slander is not a
unique concept for our time it occurred
back then as well and the group of
epicureans were heavily slandered
through this principle of hedonism and
and try to print them as this sort of uh
sex-mongering orgy porgy alcohol
drunkards uh group of people and that's
worked successfully for many many years
until scholars decided actually no
there's plenty evidence to show complete
opposite that this was all fabricated
and in fact the truth is that they were
quite ecstatic in
in the terms of practicing their own
self-discipline so when you say they're
technically hedonistic what that means
is that to them the highest pleasure is
a clear mind from free from any of the
pain
their goal is to achieve pleasure but
also eliminate pain and they divide very
cleverly i think pleasure into three
categories number one is what we all
need which is a shelter home
relationships something that we all sort
of depend on more or less number two is
things that we want such as luxuries sex
alcohol much like the stoic they they
say you know it's it's okay to indulge
in these things but practice it in
moderation and considering their request
is quite aesthetic you know they
understood the dangers of on indulging
in these things and then you have the
last one which is things that you want
but they are just bad for you in general
sorry which is power being famous
and the principle here is that
you will never have enough of these
things you will never be satisfied
having these things uh very few people
go and say hey you know what i have
enough money now thank you jeff bezos
isn't really going hey you know what i
got enough fame and power i'm quite
pleased now no everyone keeps pursuing
these things uh at least most people do
because they have no limit and i would
actually argue that the these two go in
the same category as
sex and and luxuries but
i'm also very heavily simplifying these
things so take it with a grain of salt
so epicurus had this garden which is on
the cover which is quite famous and
referenced by a lot of people i think it
was used as this area where you would
teach yourself to not be dependent on
these luxuries and sort of things uh and
and garden is quite fitting for that if
i remember i think it was socrates that
that was pondering of what things are
good and what things are bad kind of
similar to
epicurus and there was this example of a
flower being this pure good because
you smell it you enjoy it and there's no
bad consequences for it but whether you
you drink alcohol you might feel good
but afterwards there's a consequence for
it and a lot of epicurrism is
knowing what these things are taking
action to avoid or engage with depending
on that so in a lot of sense it makes
sense that the science of happiness in
the terms of
knowing what things are good for us
there's virtue in in knowing basically
so
in that sense we can take measures in
life of not feeling pain later maybe you
enjoy smoking well we know that causes
cancer so you might want to avoid that
and that's the sort of net positive and
net the
loss that epicurism is based on trying
to compare you know is it worth it is it
worth engaging with these things if
you're practicing asceticism it's a
balance basically and the same thing
when you're practicing asceticism in
self-discipline you know if you're
gaining more pain from
withstanding from things in the long run
obviously you know doesn't that kind of
feed the whole purpose epicurusism also
focus a lot on
mental pain and and they put that up as
a worse in physical pain because it
happens before
during and after so they link that with
the
this might be come out a bit out of
nowhere but i i did like this passage as
someone who's dealt with a lot of
anxiety myself they sort of use this
principle of avoiding mental pain by uh
talking about fear of death for example
second you should accustom yourself to
believing that death means nothing to us
since every good and every evil lies in
sensation but death is the pervasion of
sensation hence a correct comprehension
of the fact that death means nothing to
us makes the mortal aspect of life
pleasurable not by conferring on us a
boundless period of time but by removing
the uranus for deathlessness there's
nothing fearful in living for the person
who has really laid hold of the fact
that there is nothing fearful in not
living so it is silly for a person to
say that he dreads death not because it
will be painful when it arrives but
because it pains him now as a future
certainty for that which makes no
trouble for us when it arrives is a
meaningless pain when we await it this
the most horrifying of evils means
nothing to us then because so long as we
are existent death is not present and
whenever it is present we are not
existent it is of no concern either to
the living or to those who have
completed their lives for the former it
is non-existent and the latter are
themselves non-existent it was also
passage uh i don't remember where it is
but it was talking about
life is long enough for someone that
lives it well
wish i could find it
read the book it's great
um so
you know since epicurism and stoicism
are quite similar i'm probably still uh
more in the stoic sort of playfield of
ideas that i prefer having pain can
always be avoided no matter what
measures you take
and having that pain be your virtue i
think is something really powerful
science is setting us free from pain but
you can also argue that science causes
pain and it creates more of these things
that we are dependent on that is
necessary in modern society to to you
engage with when we're talking about the
things that we absolutely necessarily
need which is a home
food and and friends you know now it
seems like you need some form of
transport to get around you need access
to the internet otherwise you can't
really be a productive member anymore
and sure we can alleviate the fear of
god by by understanding things about you
know the heavenly bodies but it doesn't
that also sort of alleviate any form of
spirituality that we had with those
things um
sure we understand that the sun is not
the sun god helios carrying it across
the sky but we understand it's just a
ball of gas or whatever that we could
literally shoot with nuclear missiles if
we so damn pleases us is there a net
loss or a net gain there i don't know
but epicurusism in is in a sense a
withdrawal from society so
you know likely they wouldn't even care
to have these sort of things anyway it's
living your life the way you do it
engage in the things that you find
positive for yourself and completely
ignore everything that doesn't that's
not necessarily a bad thing and i think
that could work for a lot of people so i
say i recommend the book check it out if
you enjoyed it smash like subscribe and
you can win a billion which of course
you wouldn't want anyway am i right
bye